ce mercredi 11 mai dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source le glaive groupement
de lutte anti-vectorielle d'insertion et
de valorisation de l'environnement a
célébré ses 10 ans créé en 2006 par le
département afin de lutter contre le
chikungunya
l'association s'est diversifiée en
mettant en place différentes prestations
dix ans d'existence du glay qui avait
été créé à l'époque pour lutter contre
l'épidémie de chikungunya et des les
foyers à des moustiques et à faire en
sorte que les foyers de dollar soit
éliminé je pense que cette première
mission a été accomplie et nous en
sommes satisfaits mais le glaive a
continué son chemin et sur l'insertion
de d'un public en contrat aidé qui a
bénéficié d'une formation d'un
accompagnement est aujourd'hui répond
aussi à une demande des populations
fragiles les personnes âgées les
personnes porteuses de handicap qui ont
besoin des lags et des arbres dans leur
cour qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer donc une une entreprise parce que
ce sont des cours qui ne rentrent pas
dans les budgets de ces ménages fragiles
les missions du glaive destinés aux
personnes âgées ou handicapées ainsi
qu'aux bénéficiaires de minima sociaux
permettent d'améliorer gratuitement leur
cadre de vie grâce au nettoyage de leur
domicile et l enlèvement des encombrants
mais auparavant ben je fais je sais
faire moi même j'étais un petit peu plus
un peu plus comment ford bien avec eux
une chute du genou une blessure d'un des
morts je n'arrivais plus bonjour d'un
grand coin donc tu vraiment que je pars
sa peine au glaive vraiment ni sont là
pour venir deux nuls c'est formidable et
c'est pour ça que je vous le dis
longueuil depuis sa création ce sont
1941 agents qui ont participé à ces
actions et qui ont bénéficié de
dispositifs d'insertion durable alliant
travail et formation professionnalisante
mois déjà j'ai intégré de paix
par rapport à ben jawad et équipe passer
sur la route intervenir chez des
particuliers
donc ça m'a donné l'envi de déposer son
cv ma lettre de motivation pour aller
travailler chez le glaive aussi pour
aider les gens a fait un an et demi que
je suis au club l'an j'ai passé ma
formation d'ouvriers du paysage en un an
j'ai obtenu mon titre ouvriers du
paysage aussi alors que notre île est
actuellement menacée par la dengue le
glaive se dit prêt à intervenir dans la
lutte contre le virus comme il l'avait
fait auparavant pour le chikungunya
nous avons des contacts avec la rs et
nous avons nous suivons de très près
l'évolution de l'épidémie sur la réunion
il est bien évident que si les autorités
font appel au glaive que ce soit l'état
où le conseil général nous sommes prêtes
à prendre toute notre part dans la lutte
contre le la dengue maintenant puisque
il faudra être très vigilant éviter que
le 16e ce début de l'épidémie ne se
transforme en catastrophe après dix ans
d'existence le glaive continue d'assumer
une véritable mission de service public
et souhaite mettre en place de nouveaux
projets autour du développement durable
par le recyclage